This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6MUIT INGLEISH
From BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English. I'm Alice.
And I'm Neil.
We're talking about old technology today, Neil.
Did you use to have any old tech, you know, a Walkman back in the 1990s
before music went digital?
No, I didn't have a Walkman, but I do have a record player.
I know you like flaired trousers, but I didn't realise you were that retro.
A record player, for those of you who don't know, is a box with a turn table or turning plate
that you put your vinyl records on to play them.
And retro means going back to styles and fashions from the past.
Well, I love my record player.
I have a large collection of vinyl records as well as cassette tapes that I inherited from my parents.
Vinyl is the plastic that records are made from.
And cassette tapes came after records, which are these small plastic cases with
audio tape on reels inside them.
Well, I don't understand your fondness for outdated stuff, Neil.
Don't be so quick to dismiss old tech, Alice.
There's been a resurgence or new rise in record sales recently here in the UK and in the US.
Some DJs have gone back to using them.
And new record stores have opened to meet the demand for vinyl.
Really?
Yes, really.
In fact, I have a question for you, Alice.
How many records were sold in the UK in 2014?
Was it A, 10,000, B, 100,000 or C, 1 million?
Well, I think it's B, 100,000.
We'll find out if you're right or wrong later in the show.
For myself, I just think vinyl sounds nicer than digital.
Has a warmer quality.
That sounds a bit technical, Neil.
Don't you think this retro trend has more to do with nostalgia for the past?
Nostalgia means thinking about the past with a mixture of warm feelings and sadness.
Well, yes, I think people who grew up with the old technology probably are nostalgia
about it.
Let's listen to music journalist Jacqueline Springer talking about cassette tapes and what they mean to her.
They were all dear love letters.
There were ways in which she started to carve out your own identity.
So, you know, when Dan and I interviewed people, we talked about,
we talked to musicians about their impressions and their influences and invariably
it was siblings or parents and you would raid those vinyl albums and you'd self-select.
Jacqueline Springer there.
So she calls cassette tapes audio love letters because people often compiled or put together
their own collection of songs on tapes and gave them to the boy or girl they liked.
Jacqueline says they recorded songs from their parents record collections onto tape
and it seems that this process helped create their musical and social identity.
Yes, I identified with the Rolling Stones, the Clash, the Sex Pistols when I was a teen.
How about your musical identity Alice?
Well, I was in love with all the boy bands from the 1990s, NSYNC, Westlife, Backstreet Boys,
take that? Unbelievable. I can see I need to make you some decent tapes of music from the 90s, Alice.
I didn't say I still like boy bands, Neil. I'm not nostalgic for my lost teenage years, unlike you.
Old tech is everywhere. Did you know that the US nuclear weapons force still uses a computer system
dating back to the 1970s with eight-inch floppy disks?
Floppy disks. You mean those flexible plastic computer disks used for storing data magnetically?
Well, I can't believe the guys in the Pentagon are nostalgic about floppy disks.
Well, a Pentagon spokesperson said it would be extremely expensive to update the system
and it still works. They plan to do it by 2020 and save a lot of space for sure.
You would need more than 130,000 eight-inch floppy disks to store 32 gigabytes of information.
Wow, that is the equivalent of an average memory stick.
Yes, but there are more people out there keen on old tech.
How do you think a DVD rental store survives in this era of online movie streaming?
Let's listen to Tara Judah, a co-director of UK rental store 20th century flicks and find out.
We've survived because of the experience of coming into this store.
It's a very human experience. It's human interaction. People come here because they want to talk
to somebody who's really knowledgeable about film. They want to have a recommendation or a
conversation about the films they've just watched. They really want to discuss those things.
So it's back to the idea of human contact. We like compiling lists of music and sharing them
with our friends and loved ones, sharing a playlist through iTunes or Spotify isn't quite the same
though. We like talking to people about the films we watch. You can always talk to me, Neil.
Now, how about giving me the answer to today's quiz question?
I asked how many records were sold in the UK in 2014. Was it A, 10,000, B, 100,000 or C, 1 million?
And I said B, 100,000. And Alice, you are, in fact, totally wrong.
Oh! The answer is C. Vinyl is booming. In 2014, sales passed 1 million albums in the UK for the first time
since 1996. The format has been steadily increasing thanks in part to the popularity of
guitar bands traditionally associated with records. Now, let's hear the words we learned today. They are
record player, turntable, retro, vinyl, cassette tapes, resurgence, nostalgia, compiled, floppy disc,
well that's the end of today's 6 Minute English. Don't forget to join us again soon. Bye bye!